so what I love is I've had a look around
and I wonder if you just where you are
just look around at the whiteboards
um see if there are any I know some of
them it's like it's writing that you
can't necessarily read but I wonder if
you can see some of the numbers some of
the diagrams that have been drawn some
of the equations okay now I'm going to
draw on that shortly before I do
what I want to do is I am going to like
what are we doing here we're trying to
get to this understand stage yeah
um we've all kind of seen you know
hopefully now by doing enough times how
to do the trick
um go home find a deck of cards in your
family's house if you can find one and
do this on your family it's very
entertaining you've performed it but
this part's eluding us at least about
half the room based on what I can see
written down okay but we're getting
there we're getting pretty close okay so
let me show you what's going on and
again you already have several of the
pieces of the puzzle okay the first
thing you've already worked out is that
it is important that I give you nine
cards right in fact when you're
performing this actually to whoever your
friends family that kind of thing what I
would suggest is rather than the way I
did it um in front of you and it made it
very obvious that there were nine cards
instead of doing that do what I just did
and I'll do it again so you can see it
right you've got the whole deck of cards
in your hand and you don't need to count
aloud you can just physically with your
hands feel what three cards feels like
and then you can do it again and then
you do it a third time and without
obviously counting up to nine you've
given them nine cards made sense okay
now some of you said to me like is it
important that there are nine cards well
in mathematics every detail it worked
finally okay we got there right
um in mathematics all the details matter
right and you could have proved this to
yourself by for example
giving your friend 10 cards or eight
cards or any other number it has to be
nine okay now why is that well let's
actually perform the tricky game but
this time I'm going to try and draw your
attention to the parts of the trick that
matter and you're going to need a
reverse to get your books out okay I
want you to take a few notes during my
explanation with this okay
so we're now doing this trick together
I'm putting you on the inside of the
magician circle now okay so being that
we're doing this trick together don't
worry about the stage crafter selecting
what card it is let's just have a look
at the top card together six of Hearts
that's the one okay
now even if you knew
that I have here's the six of hearts and
I've given you nine cards right and you
can just count one two three one two
three one two three okay
okay fantastic good even if you notice
that there were nine cards I was
actually doing despite the fact that
this isn't a magic trick it's a
mathematical trick I was actually doing
something that magicians do all the time
which I don't know if anyone's heard
this word before it's called
misdirection misdirection
um you can even tell what it is by the
name it's directing your attention away
from where the really important things
are happening and distracting you right
now the misdirection I did was I said
look nine cards pick from these nine
right the really important number was
not nine some of you have worked out
what the really important number is the
really important number is the rest of
these cards that I handed to Arya right
some of you have written it on the board
right how many cards did I hand to Arya
at the start 43 very good 43 cards
here's the six of hearts and in fact if
you just have a look at that whiteboard
in the back right hand corner of the
room right you'll see you're about to
see the diagram I'm going to sort of do
here right here's the 43 cards there's
your card and there's eight cards
underneath it right
bam I've just put on top
not a rhetorical question the six of
hearts that we're trying to find what
position is it from the top of the deck
44. please write that down position 44
from the top of the deck okay and now we
begin the trick
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one zero now
this whole time it looks like I'm just
counting right but actually I'm doing
that thing I mentioned at the start I'm
misdirecting you still you just
hopefully don't realize the number
you're thinking about is the number that
I said aloud it's the number that you're
like seeing it's zero right but zero is
not the important number the really
important number is right how many cards
are in this pile there are 11 cards
because I counted down from ten and then
there was the the zero card right so
there's 11 cards you might want to drop
that down in this pile okay
11. how many times did I do this again
four times
ten
okay now again I'm still misdirecting
you which is why this trick worked the
first time and you were like what the
number you're thinking of is the number
I sell out 10. the number you're looking
at is 10 but the number that really
matters is how many cards are in this
pile which is
one what's ten plus one
it's 11 again 10. just suppose it's not
10 because we've already done ten nine
eight seven six five four
okay
the number you shouldn't be thinking of
is four the number you should really be
thinking about is
count them up there's seven cards here
plus four gives you
11. last time ten okay fine you get the
idea right the whole idea here is I
really want to get four piles up to 11
because that gives me four the elevens
is 44 which you already know is where
our card is but the whole idea is like
how many cards are missing in this pile
to get up to 11 answer four cards how
many cards are missing in this pile to
get up to 11 answer zero Cuts it's
already there right so when I'm adding
up those numbers it's just the total
number of additional cards I need what
is it in this case
24 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24. you
hardly even bat an eyelid now then of
course it's the six of Hearts because
numerically it has to be okay so
what we're trying to get at here is the
understand stage do you see really all
we're doing is just fancy counting
that's all that makes this work but I
want to test and we've got 15 minutes to
do it if you really really understand
I'd like you to transform this trick I
want you to do make up your own
different version of this same trick
here's what I want you to change or
rather here's what I want to stay the
same you're still going to have some
number of piles of cards here right
you're still going to be counting down
from something but I want you to change
the numbers up maybe you don't have four
piles maybe you don't count down from 10
maybe you count down from nine or eight
now when we change those numbers you're
going to change how many cards you have
to give to the person you're performing
the trick on and that's what I want you
to see if you can work out if you change
the number of piles or if you change the
number you're counting down from
how many cards are you supposed to give
to make the trick work good luck do it
as many times as you like see what you
come up with